[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález nuestro tema
de debate de hoy nos lleva hasta eeuu en
donde los jueces de la corte suprema
comenzaron las audiencias de los
defensores y también los proveedores de
los servicios de aborto en el estado de
texas para presentar una impugnación
judicial a la ley antiaborto de ese
estado en particular cuyas restricciones
prácticamente han terminado con esta
práctica en el segundo estado más grande
de los eeuu después de que las mujeres
sobrepasen la sexta semana de embarazo
más detalles en el siguiente informe de
la redacción de france 24
los jueces de la corte suprema
escucharon los argumentos de quienes se
oponen a la ley antiaborto que rigen
texas
son ciudadanos del común los que pueden
demandar a quienes ayuden a una mujer a
abortar si su proceso tiene éxito pueden
llegar a recibir diez mil dólares de sus
derechos esto no se limita al aborto
este es el punto que se ha planteado se
limita a cualquier ley que no le guste
algún estado de sars fireware dicho
mecanismo podría ser replicado y usado
en otros ámbitos como por ejemplo el
acceso a las armas este argumento parece
haber calado con al menos dos de los
jueces del ala conservadora de la corte
emi con ibarra y bread cava no
designados por donald trump y que en
septiembre votaron para permitir que la
ley text anna entrará en vigor ellos
podrían ahora reconsiderar sus posturas
lo que daría vía libre a los intentos
legales para bloquear definitivamente la
ley considerada inconstitucional
nos complace obviamente que varios de
los magistrados tuvieran preocupaciones
sobre las amplias implicaciones si se
permite a un estado de anular un derecho
federal a través de un esquema como el
sub-8 de texas skin white sox esas page
la sub-8 de texas es la normativa más
restrictiva del país permitiendo que una
mujer solo aborto esta semana de
gestación cuando puede ser detectado un
latido y cuando muchas de ellas ni
siquiera saben que están embarazadas la
controvertida ley tampoco permite que
las mujeres interrumpan su embarazo en
casos de incesto violación
lo que todavía está en duda o que por lo
menos no es muy claro es cuando el
tribunal dictaminará si emite una orden
para bloquear esta ley o si le da un
aval a los proveedores de estos
servicios de aborto en texas para que
puedan pedir al tribunal la suspensión
después de tres horas de escucha en esta
primera audiencia algunos de los jueces
indicaron que claramente hay vacíos pero
de qué tipo va a esto en contra de la
constitución del país y de las garantías
de derechos y de libertades de las
ciudadanas estadounidenses que dicen las
mujeres como se ven afectadas lo vamos a
debatir en unos minutos aquí en france24
y para analizar este tema hemos invitado
a jimena casas investigadora para las
américas de la división de mujeres en
human right watch ella se encuentra en
la ciudad de madrid' en españa también
está con nosotros paula saldaña
coordinadora de campo del instituto
nacional de latinas para la justicia
reproductiva ya se encuentra en el
estado de texas en la ciudad de
brownsville y también aquí en el estudio
de france 24 está con nosotros cristina
rosero arteaga ella es asesora legal del
centro de derechos reproductivos
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en facebook
en instagram y en twitter síganos como
france24 guión bajo s y santi logo les
recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 pues ya tenemos parte
del contexto tenemos a las invitadas y
el tema y comienzo preguntándole a
jimena en la ciudad de madrid allí en
españa porque el gobierno de texas está
impulsando este tipo de leyes que pone
por encima tal vez valores religiosos
por encima a las libertades que se
pueden garantizar en este país
norteamericana cuál es su opinión
bueno buenas noches y muchísimas gracias
santiago por por la invitación y vemos
que esto es una
oportunidad más utilizan los grupos que
van en contra de la defensa de los
derechos de las mujeres en contra de los
derechos humanos y constitucionalmente
reconocidos en eeuu desde el brou
version weight para limitar el ejercicio
legítimo y constitucional
que tienen las mujeres y han llegado
hasta estas situaciones inadmisibles que
han generado una gran indignación en los
eeuu y por eso en este momento se están
generando estas audiencias para
solicitar la impugnación de esta ley en
el estado de texas paula saldaña la
misma pregunta para partir en este
debate porque están impulsando este tipo
de medidas allí en el estado de texas
que tiene en particular a nivel político
a nivel social que le ha dado
prácticamente vía libre para que haya
entrado ya en vigor hace poco más de un
mes
mira pues que te puedo decir nosotros
aquí en tejas siempre hemos enfrentado
muchas barreras para acceder a este
servicio en particular
yo te puedo hablar acerca de lo del
campo lo que yo puedo ver y cómo hace
como estas leyes afectan a las personas
especialmente en mi comunidad yo estoy
en una comunidad en la frontera donde a
100 100 millas de donde yo vivo hay lo
que se llaman como retales como como 6
en check points es donde esta
inmigración estacionado y previene que
las personas que no tengan documentos
puedan acceder este servicio en otros
estados entonces es otra barrera que
estamos enfrentando no es nada nuevo
pero si nos da mucha tristeza de que ha
llegado a este extremo
y christina aquí en el estudio de france
24 para completar esta primera ronda la
misma pregunta qué intereses puede haber
a nivel político qué composición tiene
en particular texas que no es el único
estado que está promoviendo este tipo de
leyes en eeuu bueno tal como ya lo
mencionaron tanto jimena como paula
tiene que ver con intentar encontrar más
formas de crear barreras a los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y éstas se
combinan con como lo mencionaba paula
otras barreras que de por sí ya existían
no texas tiene una serie de regulaciones
que de por sí ya hacen difícil el acceso
a la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo y en últimas tienen un efecto
muy importante y es que afectan a
aquellas mujeres que tienen mayores
dificultades para acceder al sistema de
salud desde el centro de derechos
reproductivos por ejemplo hemos visto
cómo se afectan más las mujeres
migrantes las mujeres de la comunidad
latina o las mujeres afroamericanas
tienen un impacto mucho más grande y
combinándose con otros factores de
discriminación porque precisamente son
estas comunidades las que más afectadas
están por la pobreza todo esto suma para
que finalmente se siga sumando a las
exclusiones y discriminaciones que
tradicionalmente ya están
continúo con usted cristina para hacer
la ronda a la inversa hay una amenaza
judicial en cuanto a los derechos
civiles en este caso como lo vio usted
aquí con este tipo de movimientos que se
están haciendo a nivel judicial sin duda
en esta ley y estas regulaciones que
crean unas limitaciones al acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
el caso de eeuu son claramente
inconstitucionales porque van en contra
del presidente de rovi white que
estableció claramente la posibilidad de
acceder a este derecho desde hace ya
casi 50 años precisamente por estas
razones que se han presentado demandas
contra esta ley buscando que su vigencia
no se presente y en cierto modo se
parece un poco a las cosas que vemos en
otros lugares de nuestro continente en
américa latina' este tipo de amenazas se
presentan constantemente pero a pesar de
este tipo de
enfrentamientos lo que se ha visto es
que poco a poco hay un camino hacia la
despenalización que permite un acceso
más amplio el caso de texas nos muestra
que hay que estar siempre vigilantes y
que estas amenazas frente a los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos no nos permiten
bajar la guardia sino que hay que
defender estos derechos en todo momento
paula en la ciudad de brownsville en el
estado de texas le pregunto por este
territorio que usted conoce muy bien es
un estado muy grande tiene una
importancia política y económica para
eeuu que tanto podría generar esto un
efecto de bola de nieve hacia otros
estados de eeuu que puedan seguir los
pasos florida ha estado muy atento a lo
que sucede allí en el estado de texas en
torno a este tema
así que exactamente si no me equivoco en
la florida ya se está hablando o ya se
introducción algo parecido a esto
entonces cuando te digo es te da
vergüenza porque en otros estados van a
van a copiar cosas que nada más van a
crear barreras y no podemos regreso a lo
mismo regreso a la comunidad donde yo
estoy no podemos negar de que aquí hay
personas indocumentadas que necesitan
este servicio y es una barrera que les
está causando más aparte no nada más la
documentación aparte aquí en tejas el
pago mínimo hay muchos trabajos que no
ofrecen beneficios pues si la persona
necesita salir a tomar días de
enfermedad para ir a hacer este servicio
entonces desde eso se trata de de crear
más barreras y ser un ejemplo para otros
estados pero pues ante ante la comunidad
son ejemplos negativos que hacen ver mal
a texas
ximena en la ciudad de madrid en españa
le pregunto por el interés político que
pueda tener esto sabemos que el estado
de texas está en poder de los
republicanos son contrarios al gobierno
federal que es demócrata puede haber
aquí intereses político simplemente por
llevar la contraria a decisiones del
gobierno federal y se pone en riesgo los
derechos ciudadanos simplemente por
hacer contrapeso político
no debería existir un riesgo político
cuando estamos hablando de derechos
humanos fundamentales
aquí la corte suprema tiene una
obligación de basar sus decisiones
conforme a derecho' las consecuencias
que esto podría tener de las acciones de
la corte suprema- tanto en el caso de
texas como próximamente en misisipí o lo
que ustedes mencionaron en florida
pueden ser nefastas desde human
rightswatch llevamos casi dos décadas
documentando el impacto de la
criminalización de la del aborto y las
consecuencias son contundentes en todos
los países donde hemos realizado estas
investigaciones la criminalización del
aborto no elimina el delito sino por el
contrario que lleva a las personas a
recurrir a procedimientos inseguros que
ponen incluso en riesgo su vida y su
salud y además también acentúa
situaciones de desigualdad y
discriminación como ya lo mencionaba
christina y además
los índices y las tasas según la
organización de un margen de tasas de
aborto es muchísimo más alta en los
países que se distinguen el acceso al
aborto así que la respuesta que debería
darse debe ser en base a derecho no debe
ser una respuesta política y debe ser
conforme a las obligaciones que tiene
eeuu frente al derecho internacional de
derechos humanos que por eso son human
righs watch amnistía internacional y el
cloud yo sustente presentamos un ómnibus
con base a esta argumentación jimena
sigo con ustedes conectados así hasta la
ciudad de madre precisamente estamos
hablando del estado de texas pero usted
menciona eeuu a nivel internacional de
este país como se encuentra en estas
garantías de estos derechos para las
mujeres estamos analizando el caso de un
estado en particular que genera
controversia pero a nivel mundial cómo
está la unión americana frente al resto
del mundo
hay que entender primero el sistema de
salud en eeuu
funciona de una manera diferente si lo
comparamos con europa por ejemplo en
donde hay un gran garantía al derecho a
la salud desde los es desde el propio
estado en eeuu la mayoría de quienes
ofrecen los servicios de salud sexual y
reproductiva y especialmente de
interrupción legal del embarazo son y
hay agencias privadas y en ese sentido
digamos por ejemplo que no estaría a la
vanguardia porque debería ser un
servicio de salud ofrecido directamente
por los estados sin embargo romper sus
wire ha sido una
sentencia ejemplar con una
jurisprudencia que ha permitido la
despenalización del aborto desde hace
más de 50 años
que llevaría a que eeuu en este momento
se pusiera en la cola de muchos países
en donde se está penalizando el aborto
por ejemplo méxico esto podría
significar que ahora que baja california
o el estado de usar el estado de
coahuila acaban de despenalizar el
aborto en cualquier causal las mujeres
de pronto también ahora en textos tengan
que viajar hasta ahora a mexico para
poder acceder a un servicio de salud al
que tenían derecho desde hace 50 años y
veamos ese retroceso claro christina en
ese orden de ideas a nivel mundial que
países lideran en este tipo de políticas
para garantizarle derecho son los sanos
procedimientos a las mujeres y todas las
garantías de salubridad en clínicas
abiertas y de fácil acceso para mujeres
de todos los rangos de la sociedad de
cada uno de los países bueno él el mejor
ejemplo son aquellos países en los
cuales se está instaurando una
regulación que únicamente trata el
aborto desde el punto de vista de un
servicio de salud y de un derecho este
es el caso por ejemplo de australia los
estados en ese país como también del
estado de nueva york entre otros casos
puntuales en donde de hecho ya no existe
una regulación penal que criminaliza el
aborto lo que ha mostrado la experiencia
en este tipo de modelos es que se amplía
mucho más la posibilidad de que las
personas accedan a este procedimiento
sin tener el miedo de ser perseguidas
penalmente ni ellos ni los profesionales
de la salud que ofrecen el procedimiento
esto por supuesto baja en una situación
considerable la mortalidad materna
asociada a los procedimientos inseguros
y además crea un ambiente favorable para
que las personas puedan acceder a otros
servicios de salud reproductiva que les
permitan tomar decisiones con tiempo y
de manera responsable
por ejemplo en el caso de colombia eso
es algo que se está proponiendo por el
movimiento causa justa la eliminación
del labor del delito de aborto el código
penal para pasar a una regulación
estrictamente sanitaria de todas maneras
la gran mayoría de países del mundo ya
empiezan a moverse hacia una
despenalización cada vez mayor
mínimamente con algunas causales pero
también en muchos casos ya más de 67
países tienen un primer periodo en el
cual se permite labor a libre
disposición de la mujer y luego se
continúan con algunas causales en los
últimos 25 años la observación que ha
hecho el centro de derechos
reproductivos es que cada vez más hay un
consenso hacia la despenalización del
aborto y hace entender que este servicio
de salud no debería tener una regulación
por vía penal es un debate a nivel
internacional que se está dando en este
momento es algo como para muchos países
paula en el estado de texas ya quiero
bajar al nivel político de este estado
ya se lo había preguntado a jimena sobre
los intereses políticos que puede haber
allí pero usted que está en el en el
lugar donde están ocurriendo estos
hechos
como ve usted los cuales pueden ser esos
intereses que tengan los republicanos a
nivel político
con este tema porque ya lo estamos
analizando acá afecta principalmente a
las mujeres más pobres a las migrantes a
las que no tienen acceso a condiciones
favorables de salud que trabajan que no
pueden ir
no pueden dejar a sus hijos para poder
ir hacerse el procedimiento o que
tampoco tienen el dinero para irse a
otro estado oa otro país en este caso
méxico para practicarse una interrupción
del embarazo
pues
no soy la experta en política yo te
puedo platicar acerca lo que yo veo en
el campo y como las leyes que ellos
introducen aceptan a las personas
directamente
está esta ley está diseñada de tal forma
que ha metido mucho miedo a aparte de
poner la restricción de las seis semanas
también hace que las personas que apoyan
a las dos personas que se encuentran en
esta situación
remueva en este apoyo de esas personas y
sabemos que es cuando alguien necesita
más de la ayuda de la gente de verdad
cosas como tan simples de que le des
transportación no leo le ayudes a
financiar un aborto o de tener en la
mano a la persona mientras está tomando
esta decisión no es cuando te digo no
soy experta en leyes te puedo decir lo
que yo veo en la comunidad como esta ley
viene y afecta y como nuestros líderes
políticos no se están dando cuenta de
cómo están afectando a las personas ya
sus familiares ya tu sistema de apoyo
bueno usted lo dice usted trabaja en el
campo en terreno que dicen las mujeres
que dicen las mujeres texanas que van a
ser afectadas en cierta forma por este
tipo de leyes si continúan hay mucha
confusión hay mucha confusión en la ley
estaba diseñada o el palabreo está medio
extraño medio raro nosotros tenemos la
fortuna de tener una persona que
desglosa la ley a manera de que pueda
entender la comunidad pero aún así los
medios por lo que publican lo que
enseñan causa que la gente se confunda
entonces ahorita hay mucha confusión la
gente no sabe si sí se pueden hacer no
se pueden hacer si los demandan o los
demandan y no saben si es legal o no es
legal entonces toda esa confusión causa
que la gente ahora esté guardando las
historias estén
escondiéndose y si se encuentran en esa
situación pues no saben a dónde recurrir
y hay miedo hay miedo en la comunidad
pero pues no es como les dije al
principio no es la primera vez que no es
la primera barrera que enfrentamos en
años pasado también enfrentamos algo no
tan extremo pero el gracias a la
organización de la comunidad
pudimos este y la corte suprema- pudimos
a vencer esa ley hace unos años entonces
esa es nuestra esperanza seguir
organizándonos y movilizando jimena este
tipo de coyunturas sociales que generan
tanto debate político y a nivel de las
sociedades dejan también en evidencia
algunas
en algunos casos puede ser la educación
no puede ser la prevención políticas de
prevención de autocuidado aquí que está
fallando para que se estén tomando estas
medidas porque el argumento que hay
entre quienes están apostándole a esta
ley es que hay que hacer algo
precisamente con este tipo de
situaciones en el caso de la
interrupción del embarazo es porque hay
un problema supuestamente que hay que
solucionar pero cuál es el problema acá
y que lo que está fallando supuestamente
el problema no es la interrupción del
embarazo el problema es la falta de
acceso a servicios integrales en salud
sexual y reproductiva y en donde las
mujeres realmente tengan un acceso a la
información un acceso adecuado sobre
todas las alternativas que tendrían para
poder ejercer su sexualidad y su
reproducción de manera libre e
independiente e s esa es la este es
realmente
el gran punto y por eso las políticas
públicas y todas las normas que te
hablan deberían irse entradas
en éste
en esta mira y vemos que cada vez la
jurisprudencia o hasta ahora av
avanzando hacia mirar estos estos temas
más como son parte del proyecto de vida
de las mujeres y por tanto hay que
abarcar los de esa manera justamente
porque hemos visto y como lo mencionaba
cristina las normas van avanzando y
vemos que cada vez hay un empuje social
y legal
a lograr ya sea una mayor
despenalización del aborto por unas
causales o para tratar de eliminar el
aborto de los códigos penales como está
pasando ahorita en colombia
porque ha habido estos avances es que
otros movimientos están tratando de
generar confusión con informaciones no
verdaderas
indicadores no ciertos si para dar
argumentaciones y lograr estos estos
retrocesos porque las evidencias
realmente han sido científicas son
claras es decir que en los países en
donde se restringe el aborto los las
tasas de mortalidad materna son
muchísimos más altos en los países donde
las que les pueden decidir sobre su
maternidad es sobre su reproducción los
índices de mortalidad materna son son
menores y aquí yo creo ser simplemente a
no tranquila adelante adelante no
simplemente concluir ya que
seguramente las mujeres detectadas las
que tengan recursos podrán viajar a
otros estados o incluso a mary oa méxico
para poder recibir esa atención médica o
encontrar algunas otras formas de
interrumpir el embarazo fuera del
sistema sanitario ching pero las
consecuencias realmente van a ser
nefastas para las jóvenes para las
personas que vivan en pobreza para las
migrantes para las poblaciones
afrodescendientes que se enfrentan a
muchas barreras como ya lo mencionaba
elizabeth para acceder a la atención al
aborto debido a esos periodos de espera
obligatorios al consentimiento paterno
obligatorio que en muchos casos tienen
que tener en texas y otras restricciones
y justamente por eso aquí todo el debate
y a lo que se está centrando cada vez el
debate no solamente en eeuu sino a nivel
probar es que el delito es ineficaz que
el uso de este de estas normas del
derecho penal de esta de estas
regulaciones está siendo abusivo que es
totalmente discriminatorio porque afecta
más a estas mujeres y personas gestantes
en estas situaciones de vulnerabilidad y
que por eso deben hacer estos cambios es
que solamente en el caso de eeuu algunas
cifras calculan que serían 36 millones
de mujeres las que tendrían que comenzar
a desplazarse hacia otros estados
vecinos en caso de que esta ley se
mantenga en texas y comience a ser
aprobada en estados como florida como
wyoming en otros estados donde también
se está contemplando y se está
debatiendo en torno a ellas y serían 36
millones las que tendrían que
desplazarse esto también generaría un
problema para las clínicas que dan estos
servicios estados cristina ya jimena
tocaba un punto importante ahí y son los
beneficios que trae tener una
interrupción del embarazo dentro del
marco legal con todas las garantías
cuáles son los beneficios sociales en la
práctica cómo se ha ejemplificado eso
hay múltiples el más importante ya lo
mencionó jimena y es una disminución
considerable en la mortalidad materna y
morbilidad asociada a los abortos
realizados en condiciones inseguras pero
además de esto esto también permite una
mejor protección de las niñas y las
adolescentes en muchos casos las niñas y
adolescentes que son víctimas de
violencia sexual usualmente no tienen la
información suficiente uno para
identificar que fueron víctimas de ese
tipo de violencia para identificar que
se encuentran embarazadas y para
identificar si pueden acceder a este
tipo de servicios tener esta regulación
de una manera exclusiva en el tema de
derechos y desde un derecho sanitario
permite un acceso mucho mejor que les
permite protegerlas y permitirles
desarrollar su proyecto de vida que no
se ha truncado por este tipo de
violencias sexuales que nos afectan
tanto
esto no solamente se refiere únicamente
a las niñas y las adolescentes al final
también le termina dando valor a los
proyectos de vida de las mujeres y se
entiende que sus proyectos de vida si
tienen un valor suficiente como para que
este tipo de derechos estén regulados y
de verdad sean protegidos de manera
general también el hecho de no tener una
amenaza penal hace que los servicios
sean más amigables porque los
proveedores de salud no se sienten
amenazados por el hecho de proveer esta
información ni tampoco la necesidad de
identificar unas causales que quizás por
la desinformación por los prejuicios o
los estigmas alrededor puedan ser
confusos para muchos de ellos entonces
eliminar este tipo de amenazas penales
hacen que los servicios de salud sean
sustancialmente mejores que se prevengan
muertes y que se prevenga enfermedades
asociadas a los abortos inseguros y más
aún permite que todas las personas
puedan estar en un ambiente más
favorable donde tomen decisiones sobre
su salud y su reproducción de una manera
informada y mucho más segura servicios
de salud garantizados y paula pero como
garantizar este tipo de prácticas dentro
de un sistema de salud como el de eeuu
prácticamente un sistema de salud
privatizado donde la gente debe pagar un
seguro adicional de su salario de sus
ingresos porque no hay una cobertura
universal como si puede haber en los
sistemas de bienestar de los países
europeos o los países nórdicos
estas son también campañas en las que
estamos trabajando estamos organizando
la comunidad así que queremos que haga
que este servicio que no nada más exista
pero también que sea accesible para las
personas de bajos ingresos
yo sé que hay mucho ahí hay una ley en
hayling que no nos permite que fondos
federales o estatales paguen por esos
servicios y afecta la comunidad porque
es la gente que más necesita son los que
aplicarían para el servicio y si no está
disponible pues es una barrera no es un
servicio muy económico entonces
aparte de todas las otras barreras del
dinero también es una falta del dinero
acceso a sería un problema muy grande
para las personas es un problema muy
grande que estamos viviendo también a
quien tenga si mira entonces en este
caso en el de estados unidos que ya
paula nos explicaba cómo hay campañas
para tratar de garantizar el acceso a
este tipo de prácticas pero no hay
riesgo que en un país como en estados
unidos donde todo es fácil volverle un
negocio la interrupción del embarazo
pueda volverse un negocio precisamente
porque no hay un sistema de salud o un
sistema de bienestar que pueda
garantizar este tipo de acceso a estas
terapias y volverlo un negocio más como
ya es la salud en eeuu un negocio
sin embargo creo que en los casos de
servicios integrales a salud sespa y
reproductiva hay organizaciones y
entidades de ámbito privado como
frankfurt
que justamente porque tienen un
compromiso con la salud de las mujeres
de las niñas de las adolescentes ofrecen
estos servicios en una gama muy amplia
en derechos sexuales y reproductivos y
tratando de abarcar esas falencias y
esos vacíos que ha dejado el sistema
sanitario en eeuu creo que
puede generarse esa situación pero en
general hemos visto que quienes
realmente ofrecen estos servicios son
profesionales de la salud comprometidos
con los derechos humanos de las mujeres
comprometidos con la salud de las
mujeres de las niñas de los adolescentes
que realmente ofrecen estos servicios y
que adecuan sus tarifas y sus los
ambientes de nuestros propios servicios
para garantizar que tengan una mayor
cobertura y una mayor accesibilidad
a una gran diversidad de personas yo
quiero conocer su opinión en torno a
este tema en que esto se vuelva un
negocio que produce muchísimo dinero y
empieza a tener unas prácticas que van
un poco más allá de lo que debe tener
como punto focal nuevamente creo que eso
vuelve a redundar en la necesidad de una
regulación adecuada en el sector de
salud en países como por ejemplo
colombia ya ha logrado incorporar la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
las tres causales dentro del plan de
beneficios mínimo que toda persona
debería tener y en muchos otros países
eso se ha ido logrando entonces por
supuesto la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo al tratarse de un servicio de
salud estará permeado por las dinámicas
propias y las dificultades propias de la
cobertura del acceso a salud de los
países pero siempre es necesario
entender que este tipo de servicios son
esenciales y al tratarse de un servicio
esencial debería estar en los mínimos
que se ofrezcan dentro de un sistema de
salud dentro de cada contexto por
supuesto cada contexto es distinto
eeuu tiene unos retos muy particulares
pero al menos desde un punto de vista
del derecho internacional de los
derechos humanos ya estos derechos son
reconocidos en la salud sexual y
reproductiva ya se reconoce como un
mínimo que debería garantizarse por los
estados y ese sería el norte para las
personas que luchamos por estos derechos
localmente adaptándonos a los contextos
y intentando superar los retos propios
del propio diseño de los sistemas de
salud en cada contexto no nos deja usted
prácticamente una de las básicas
reflexiones y conclusiones del programa
que es un marco regulatorio bien armado
en cada uno de los países llegamos a la
recta final del programa quiero hacer
las conclusiones comienzo con christina
aquí en el estudio de france 24 lo que
pueda suceder
lo digo no hay bola de cristal no
sabemos el futuro de lo que pueda
suceder con este tema pero esta ley
usted cómo lo ve que pueda progresar que
sea desmontada en texas que eeuu le dé
el espaldarazo y se abra al debate para
instaurar una política un poco más
organizada en torno a este tema como lo
ve usted bueno nosotros tenemos
confianza en que la corte suprema tiene
una serie de jurisprudencia muy sentada
en la protección de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos y
particularmente de robbie white como un
precedente absolutamente importante en
esta regulación y por supuesto sería
extremadamente preocupante que la corte
no falle en derecho y desconozca estos
presentes constitucionales y por
supuesto como este referente podría
volverse para otro tipo de estados
dentro del mismo
eeuu
creemos que es muy importante que la
corte en este sentido proteja los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos no
solamente de las mujeres personas sino
también de todas las mujeres en estados
unidos y por supuesto seguiremos
trabajando para que no solamente en eeuu
sino en todo el resto del continente
estos derechos se hagan una realidad
paula su conclusión sobre este tema que
va a suceder allá en su estado en el
estado de texas va a prosperar este
intento por desmontar la ley se va a
mantener va a ver aquí un rifirrafe
político como lo vio usted
pues como te digo lo que yo veo y lo que
siento en la comunidad y por los años
que tengo experiencia de trabajar en la
comunidad
estoy segura que vamos a poder vencer
esto vamos a seguir organizándonos el
año que entra vienen elecciones muy
importantes todas las elecciones son
importantes pero el año que entra vienen
elecciones
la verdad que legislativas y el asiento
del gobernador entonces este vamos a
seguir nosotros mientras organizando la
comunidad educando las siguiendo
hablando acerca del tema que esto es una
manera de poder romper todo el tabú de
poder sacar más historias para que
nosotros podamos conectar eso iu y
ayudarle a esas personas a que alguien
sus voz ya través de su voz tenga sepan
que tienen el poder
este el que más te puede decir seguir
organizándonos inmovilizando la
comunidad lo mejor que puedan bueno pues
movilización desde la comunidad desde
las mujeres allí en texas movimientos
para hacer oír su voz y jiménez la
ciudad de madrid' su conclusión
yo añadiría
diciendo que yo creo
en las instituciones creo en el poder
del derecho y creo que el aporte suprema
de justicia tiene una amplia
jurisprudencia que no solamente en este
tema de aborto sino en otros temas que
también
harían preguntas sobre sobre este
proyecto de ley usted lo mencionan al
principio en el informativo de una de
las preguntas específicas de 7
inconstitucional que los gobiernos
estatales puedan autorizar a
particulares para demandar a otras
personas simplemente porque tienen la
corazonada de que alguien te hizo un
aborto no que eso podría tener
ramificaciones en otras circunstancias
en otras situaciones no solamente en
situaciones del aborto ya hemos visto
como dos jueces conservadores eso es
algo que los ha hecho pensar y yo creo
que la corte suprema de justicia en eeuu
se ha caracterizado
también por ser rigurosa en el análisis
del derecho y esperemos que escuchando
las argumentaciones
de quienes están acompañando a los
proveedores puedan entender mejor los
impactos de esta ley porque este no es
no poder ser un experimento controlado
ya hemos visto que los proveedores
de servicios de salud sexual
reproductiva en texas han tenido que
fechas para varias pacientes y ya hemos
visto como quienes están en situación de
mayor vulnerabilidad son quienes están
poniendo más incluso su vida y su salud
en riesgo así que esperemos que la
jurisprudencia sea la que prevalezca
pues a jimena a paula y a christina aquí
en el estudio de france 24 les agradezco
por haber compartido con nosotros sus
puntos de vista ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]